der fall ereignete sich vor zwei jahren
in einer in einem kleinen bistro in der
innenstadt der das spätere opfer model
von dem korb dass er sein selbst
mitgebrachtes fleisch grillen dürfen
das hat der koch verweigert und der
streit eskalierte letztendlich in einer
unglaublichen kundschaft ja und was
genau wurde heute neu verhandelt ja also
vor dem amtsgericht kam zur sprache dass
der beklagte wohl zuerst in einer
notwehrsituation gehandelt hatte der
junge mann spätere opfer gegen stühlen
und mit flaschen auf ihn los er wehrte
sich zunächst nur das amtsgericht
wertete das als eine notwehrsituation
und vorteile ihnen lediglich zu zwei
jahren auf bewährung viel zu wenig für
die staatsanwaltschaft die ford hat
heute natürlich knast für den koch